مشكله اخرى فرضها القانون الجديد على افلا
رسميا باتا امام الشركه 24
شهرا ليتم استخدام الشاحن من نوع سي لجميع
الهواتفها مثل المستخدمه في جميع الاجهزه
الذكيه هل ابل واحده معنيه بهذا القرار
طبعا له جميع شركات التكنولوجيا التي تبيع
منتجاتها في اوروبا من ملزمه لتصنيع اجهزه
محموله ملائمه لشواحن من هذا النوع اذا
لماذا نركز على قبل
تحتكر اكبر حصه سوقيه من بيعها داخل
اوروبا وبالنسبه تصل الى 55% فكره الشاحن
المشترك لجميع الاجهزه جاءت وفقا لحل ثلاث
قضايا اساسيه واولها جعل المنتجات اكثر
استدامه وتقليل النفايات الالكترونيه
وتسهيل الحياه المستهلكين في اوروبا نهج
امراه قفل انه يتعارض مع الاهداف الثلاثه
اذ لا يعقل ان يضطر اكثر من مليار مستخدم
الى التخلص من شواحن اللايتنج الحاليه
والشراء موصل لربط الشاحن الجديد وقد
يختلف الطرفان لكن الكل متفق على ضروره
تخفيض بصمته الكربونيه من النفايات
الالكترونيه تخيلوا ان البشر في عام 2001
20 فقط فخلصوا من النفايات الكترونيه
حجمها صوره الصين العظيم نتحدث عن ثلاثه
و60 مليون طن تقريبا من النفايات المرصوصه
على مسافه واحده و20 الف كيلو متر هناك
سور اخر من هذه النفايات موجود في اوروبا
ويمتد من اصله الى طرف ايطاليا على مسافه
3500 كيلو متر تقريبا وبارتفاع 10 امتار
هذا يمثل
ملايين 700 الف طن من النفايات
الالكترونيه والنسبه تزيد اثنين في المائه
كل عام اذا اخذنا الشواحن وحدها فهي تمثل
ما بين احد عشر الى 13 مثل النفايات وتخرج
انبعاثات تخرج انبعاثات عفوا بحجم 600 الى
900.000 طنن من مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون
تتخيل كيف سيكون تاثير الانبعاثات
انبعاثات الشواحن فقط على البيئه من
الهواء الذي نتنفسه الى الغذاء الذي ناكله
ومن اللحم
والعالم مع العلم ان الطن الواحد فقط من
انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون يعادل قياده
سيارات تعمل بالديزل لمسافه سته الاف
كيلومتر عمليا تكمل مشكله الانبعاثات ابي
طريقه تصريفها والتخلص منها والحل
يبدا من هنا
[موسيقى]